[موسيقى]
والله يا ابو يوسف رجل من هالرجال لا اكثر
ولا قليل والله يعني مو ناس بطيء بو ناس
سوقان بالعرف عرفت دلال حنا انا لا الحين
ترى مبتدئ انا ما ابتدي بالحياه ما يعني
ولا واحد بالميه صراحه
[موسيقى]
اول حمصه كنت اول متوسط او ثاني متوسط
ما انتبهت بصراحه
استخرج ثاني
مره مرتين
يوم جيت وانا اجلس على القهوه
[موسيقى]
بس العام كنت هنا هناك
اي والله حلو وقريب وسهل يعني اللي بيجي
حدا وشيء سهل
كان الاولين يعني
يلا نروح نتقهوى عنده
[موسيقى]
م معذب
عمرك
هذه السنه
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للمصنع
تاسس المصنع 1403 لكن قبل فكره الولد قبل
398 هذا الكلام الوالد لي
ثلاث سنين لين انت صحيح 100%
هذه من ابداعات اللي طال عمرك الو سميناه
دله ابو يوسف بالنسبه للدله هذه هذه دخلت
عليها يمكن اربع اجل
عندك المشرب طولته الغطاء خليته البغدادي
الدله على دقه هادي صالح
عندك العجوز رفعت شوي من هنا بالعادي يجي
نازل
حساوي
دائما يصير هذه قصير بعيد
والوقت هذا اللي يجيك ترى هو متجمع انا
فاتح امبابه زين بيض الله وجهه لكن بيجي
اكثر
القهوه الهيل وايش بهار البيت
ارجع يا جوا رجال للبيت وادخلوا رجال
للبيت تبارك سبحان الله البيت ويصير له
اييي قيمه ويصير له طعم البيت
لا مسكني في وجه حايم
هذا العاذر عادر ورطه
[موسيقى]
يعني تركب يعني البغدادي يعني مجسمات من
تراب يرسمون خلى الوقت
[موسيقى]
شوفوا الشجر شوفوا للحياه شوفوا
طبيعه الارض ما راح يعني تصوره يعني لو
يجلس في البيت طول حياه ما راح يتصور يعني
اول شيء نظرته عندنا قهوه
الاول
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
كسر برزانك الحين
الوقت يا محمد المحاده وعلى وقت طلال
والله ما ادري محمد
[موسيقى]
يعني انها طيبه زي كذا اللون وقال اني
مشتهيه قال ليش كبيتها فنجان قال القهوه
[موسيقى]
حق القهوه
نمل هذا العوف ايش الخلاوي يميز هالطعم
وحبه صغيره
يقول دق قهوه وبحر بدله صغيره كبر هذه
وحط البهار وهذا وصلح القهوه وطعمه يقول
معه ثلاث
رجال موجود بالغرفه دار 14 رجال
ويرجع على الاول
ما خلف القهوه
مختصه زي ما قالوا قحوت مختصه تقهوى ما
عندي مشكله امر لكوفي انا مشتهيه كل يوم
لكن انا ابقى على علمان على مانع عليه ما
تصنعه على الشكل الجديد ما تصنع مهما
ارتفعت او نزلتها بقد علمت عليه مصيرك اخر
شيء لا تراب الملوك الحين الملوك مهما
وصلوا من التطور يعني
ما يقدمون
صحيح تحلت رسلات صحيح
تقاوي صبروا يا وقف وبغى يصب طال عمرك
صحيح واقف صحيح شامخ
عشان ام مالك ما توقع عشان الحضور حاله
فخر فخر السعوديه
تنكسر بعدين
[موسيقى]